aussi matière des gadgets cette semaine
on va parler
vous avez sans doute reconnu l'haïti
l'extraterrestre qui voulait retourner
chez lui qui s'était construit est
téléphone avec des joies qu'il avait
trouvé sur terre le des joies qu'il
avait trouvé c'est ce dont veut nous
parler cette semaine je n'ai que
tremblay oui c'est une petite console
orange muni d'une poignée qui était
largement popularisé justement dans tes
c'était speak and spell la dictée
magique en français et c'est ça qu'on
déterre du cimetière des gadgets donc
c'était pour apprendre l'orthographe
notamment vous en paierez peut-être pour
jouer aux pendus c'était probablement le
premier sinon l'un des premiers gadget
qui était pourvue d'une voie
électronique et surtout un bel outil
d'apprentissage autistes et construit
son téléphone avec le speak and spell
j'en ai parlé avec carl charest qui est
spécialiste en communication numérique
et aux médias sociaux et comme vous
allez l'entendre ses souvenirs sur la
dictée magique sont encore assez clair
si ma mémoire est bonne j'avais des amis
qui en avait un à la maison et à chaque
fois que j'allais pour moi c'est est le
jouet qui était toujours pour moi le
centre d'attraction ya personne qui se
battait avec moi pour la voir les moines
à sa matière et structures enfin j'étais
quand même assez solitaire dans la vie
donc d'avancer une interaction avec
d'enfance qui est un des premiers
ordinateurs avec une voix hyper
robotisée qui faisait part à certains
mais qui - m'inspirait plein de trucs
donc quelqu'un qui en avait une dans
votre famille une dictée magique et vous
en avez reçu une vous même un peu après
c'est sa voix exact et je pense si ma
mémoire est bonne je pense qu'ils
étaient anglophones et le but de mes
parents c'était demain d apprendre
l'anglais
dans mon souvenir je jouais beaucoup
avec ça mais moi je pense que c'était
beaucoup plus éducatif que un jus dictée
magique de texas instruments les multis
parle et il ne faisait pas assez comme
c'était électronique
il ne faisait pas assez comme du jeu
parce qu'il y avait deux voix robotisée
mais c'était juste l'apprentissage je
pense que avec plein de facteurs mais ça
fait partie du fait que si je suis
bilingue aujourd'hui
bayo ohu en partie cette machine noah
qui m'ont appris plusieurs mots ça fait
partie des joueurs que j'aurais aimé
pouvoir passer à mon fils juste pour
qu'ils puissent voir la différence entre
un tablet qui lui-même sur trois ans
comprend déjà comment la faire
fonctionner et c'était quoi ma réalité
ma tablette à moi c'est d'imagés
d'enfants
ça fait partie des briques qui ont bâti
mon univers
puis qui me donne envie que mes enfants
soient aussi créatif et aussi allumé que
je l'étais de par l'utilisation de ces
machines
ça fait penser aux premières voix
robotisée honorable dans roue téléphone
au début oui à ton appel à certains
endroits mais c'est quoi les effets
sonores qu'on attendait c'est une
utilisation récente justement de dictée
magique au cours des dernières années
on l'a trafic en quelque sorte pour
faire de nouveaux sons ajoute des
boutons qu'on tourne un peu comme vous
savez du scratch
ils appellent ça du building et je
termine en vous disant vous vous
rappellerez peut-être le premier album
de du groupe depeche mode qui était qui
avait pour titre
pickens perles rue ste marie celui sur
lequel on trouvait just can't get enough
donc eu quand même une on pourrait dire
une influence sur la culture populaire à
travers un thé et d'autres
manifestations comme ça
merci beaucoup je vous en prie donc